there is nothing Admiral Nelson can't
see from up there but he's not alone
everyone who crosses Trafalgar Square
London's biggest public space is under
constant surveillance nobody knows
exactly how many cameras there are in
London but on a single day you can be
easily filmed some 300 times in Europe
this is the closest you get to a
surveillance society on one of the most
closely watched squares these two will
also watch you like a hawk Rosie and
Lizzie Harris Hawks who have been busy
here as pest control birds in order to
keep pigeons away I'm told Lizzie here
she was up on Canadian hairs top of the
roof we had a little mess but a lot of
wool just over there and she come down
and swooped and but we are one of their
favorite spots is located in the
southeast corner of the square here
Scotland Yard hollowed out a lamppost in
1926 and adapted it for police purposes
also installing a telephone from now on
the square was under surveillance tells
me Anthony if this was the center of
London if this is where all the big
demonstrations were taking place if this
is where trouble was likely to come from
it was absolutely vitally important that
the police could keep abreast of what
was going on in one of the earlier
demonstrations in the 1886 demonstration
the police try to be in plain clothes in
amongst the crowd and that proved a
complete failure because they couldn't
get their messages out to say where the
demonstrators might be going to cause
trouble so having a fixed box where
indeed the policeman could actually be
inside if you wanted to protect it from
the public was seen as a big advantage
today the police box is only used to
store cleaning equipment what would I
have found here at the time
not not a lot just a telephone basically
and I guess maybe a really good reports
book or something to fill him that that
was it at earls court Antony shows me
what police boxes typically looked like
towards the end of the 1960s the
increased availability of walkie-talkies
signaled the beginning of the end for
the police box thanks a lot for taking
me through the era of police boxes from
the beginning at Trafalgar Square to the
end here at us court well that's an
absolute vision thanks a lot good hot
tea I hope you're not under too much
surveillance as you go round unlikely or
could the era of mass surveillance come
to a sudden end just like the police
boxes 20 years ago the British
government begged a major expansion of
the CCTV network but now funds are being
cut and cameras shut off studies found
that CCTV had little effect on crime
deterrence other than car crimes tells
me David Mary spokesperson for no CCTV
nevertheless the system is being
upgraded instead of having all this this
old CCTV cameras are the replacing them
with much deeper camera Rosa which I
higher-resolution Wallace internet based
on so they can control them remotely and
share their mature much more easily
already police forces in the UK have
access to an extensive automatic number
plate recognition network initially
intended for collecting a congestion fee
now they can track all car movements and
with a face recognition software David
warns they could also drag people to be
watched you don't need surveillance
cameras anymore or camera crews for that
matter your mobile phone has become the
device to observe others
you can see who crosses London Bridge or
the iconic zebra crossing at Abbey Road
made famous by the album cover of The
Beatles private and domestic webcams
provide a close to real-time insight
into the lives of Londoners including of
course Trafalgar Square after all this
surveillance frenzy I decided to
withdraw to the one spot in Trafalgar
Square where it all began here I can
monitor others but no one will see me at
least I thought so all right I think
we're done who knows when your own
mobile really switches off and stops
watching you
you